come and see whatever smell
alhamdulillah said amo alaikum peace be
unto you thank you for tuning in last
week we were discussing with dr. Gerald
Dirk's
graduate of Harvard University you can
hear his story of how he came to embrace
the way of life of all the messengers of
God which is that surrender and
submission sincerely obediently and in
peace something with one word Islam how
he came to it on his special section at
the Deen show calm and we have covered
part one you can go back to look at that
we're going to continue on talking with
him when we come back here on the Deen
show the topic is DZ's Jesus peace be
upon him divine that ever claimed
divinity and we come back here in the
Dean show part two to this topic
I love that you know
there's only one Jesus was his messenger
no I did that maybe it maybe it's just
to break the ice
assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam how are
you good
praise God all right yes I'm the law
praise and thanks to the creator of the
heavens and earth and we are continuing
talking about for those who join us last
week you gave an overwhelming amount of
evidence supporting that Jesus peace be
upon him never claimed divinity we
talked about this we also covered that
his disciples didn't look at him as a
God and some of the earlier Christian
groups at that time who believe in a
adoption Astari yes this is a theory or
the belief that he was known as a son of
God meaning a righteous servant of God
is that how Jewish people at that Tiger
would consider and and and you know we
could look at how this whole Mis notion
yeah evolved on first century Palestine
if you said so-and-so was the son of God
everyone knew that what you meant by
that was this is a very righteous and
pious and god-fearing individual and
that's all you were saying that's all
you were meaning and like I say the Jews
in Palestine all knew this the problem
that arose is when Paul took his
particular brand of Christianity and
began to teach it to the Gentiles or the
non-jews in Asia Minor and more
specifically in Europe and when these
pruple heard the word son of God it
meant something very very different to
them then it meant to those Jews back in
Palestine who when they heard it said
yeah righteous man religious man pious
man
but when Greeks heard it or Roman's
heard it this conjured up images of the
Gods coming down from Mount Olympus
impregnating human women
and you have someone like Hercules being
born as the result so this was the
context in which these Gentiles began to
receive the message that Paul was
bringing to them when they heard that
term son of God or they were saying oh
yes I know exactly what you mean we have
our own stories of the Gods coming down
from Mount Olympus and be getting
children by mortal women so they took it
in a very different direction and that
translation was never appropriately made
from first century Palestine and Judaism
to Europe so when you take a language
that's suited because did it not say in
what we allegedly have in the Bible that
Jesus's have allegedly said that I have
not been sent except to the lost sheep
of the house of Israel yeah we have that
statement in the Gospel of Matthew
mm-hmm it's a story of a Canaanite women
he's he's a traveling and a Canaanite
woman comes up to him and starts
shouting after him saying you know lord
help me help me my daughter's tormented
by a demon and we're told and Jesus did
not answer her at all and she keeps
yelling and finally the disciples come
up to Jesus and say you know send her
away she's harassing us and Jesus said I
was not sent except to the lost sheep of
the house of Israel
and the woman finally approaches him and
says you know please you know and Jesus
says you know again yeah I was sent only
to the Israelites you don't take the
food that's been for the children and
and feed it to the dogs yeah and the
woman supposedly says yes but even the
dogs eat the crumbs that fall from their
master's table and so we're told in
Matthew Jesus as great as your faith be
it as you wish and her daughter was
healed instantly but the point is that
he was saying I was him only to the lost
sheep of the house of Israel and the
people of Israel
Jews the people of Palestine knew what
Son of God meant which was simply a
righteous pious man so if you take that
where he was only sent for the children
of Israel and now they can understand
the language son of God as you had given
that evidence that that meant a
righteous person and then you gave in
part one all the evidence that this
Bible literally has sons by the tons yes
and now you take this language in the
and you take it outside of his immediate
mission and now we give an example for
instance if I take the slang for
instance or the language of this time
and maybe I take it back or forward 100
200 years and for instance you tell a
person to I need a lift
uh-huh right so that would translate I
need a ride but somewhere else they
think of a lift yes elevators or you
know this guy's bad yes now that can
mean that someone say he's a bad person
but in another slang he's bad he's like
Oh awesome
yeah another one is mary had a little
lamb you know if you take this literally
and this is just a story or but someone
would think that she actually gave birth
to a lamb so is this kind of the same
thing what we're saying that you take a
language that suited for this time
understood by this people and you bring
it over here by people who are already
worshiping sons gods Apollo Jupiter he
had a son Mithras and now you can see
how this gets all mixed up and go
absolutely absolutely
yeah that is amazing so tell us now
moving on someone because we refuted
some of the evidence that someone tries
to use saying that Jesus no no no he is
a divine and okay we're gonna just for
the benefit of doubt someone's really
sincere we hope and he has some other
verses that aren't the back of his mind
we want to clear these up I and the
father are one tell us someone might use
this and saying look look look he said I
and the father are one and they want to
support him being divine what you gotta
say what does it mean doc you and I one
my wife and I are one in the purpose huh
yeah sure
so I mean to say my father and I are one
what does that mean you know it's a very
ambiguous statement yeah can be
interpreted a number of different ways
yeah so no one comes to the Father
except through me was that mean to the
message that Jesus taught the same
message that we as Muslims accept that's
makes sense how about he said when they
came to him and he said before Abraham
was I hear this all the time I am the
famous I am now and they compared it to
the Old Testament where God you know it
better than me where the Moses and tell
them I am can you expound on this wow
they're doing a little pun on the words
there but as far as the pre-existence of
Jesus yeah that doesn't imply divinity
by any stretch of the imagination
we as Muslims believe that all of Adam's
seed for of all time had a spiritual pre
existence in which we testified to God
about his oneness etc and so you know in
that sense we were all pre-existent yeah
so this is again one of those that if
you went to an average layman and you
took that verse and you like showed it
to them and you said what do you get out
of this I don't think too many people
are going to get that Jesus is divine or
you know one with God would you well
yeah it's a we talked about it an
earlier show there's this concept
psychology called the Rorschach test or
shark testing which is a series of ink
blots on cards you hand it to a person
you say what do you see in this well
whatever the person sees whether it's a
cloud or an animal or a butterfly or
what-have-you
is something that they themselves are
projecting onto the inkblot and so many
of these verses you know my father and I
are one and no man cometh unto the
father but by me I am the way the truth
and the life you know these are all
Rorschach cards yeah you're going to get
out of them what you're projecting into
them what you really wanted to say
you're seeing that but if you're going
to use that standard Isaac
the board is not the same as some of the
other verses that are actually
unequivocal where maybe you can help us
out with that where he's clearly making
a distinction between him and God oh
there are a number of such verses and
you give us some of those well sure we
can in fact why don't I enlist your aid
here brother
because I wrote a few of them down I
thought those might come up yes and see
beginning here where it says biblical
verses supporting subordination ISM if
you want to just read off what it's
asking for I'll try and look it up real
quickly yeah you got here in mark 10:18
okay let's see what mark 10:18 says and
I'm reading from the New Revised
Standard Version Jesus said to him why
do you call me good
no one is good but God alone I mean
that's that's kind of you know not
leaving room for you know too much
interpretation I mean it's straight to
the point yeah yeah tell us John 5:19
this is John 5:19 jesus said to them
very truly I tell you the son can do
nothing on his own but only what he sees
the father doing for whatever the father
does the son does likewise son can do
nothing on his own so if he's God he
should be able to do everything sure I
mean and he's saying that he can't do
nothing yeah he is clearly saying he's
subordinate to God okay we don't need
actually even your master's degree to
figure this one right there yeah
okay how about John 35 35 30
okay again words of Jesus supposedly I
can do nothing on my own as I hear I
judge and my judgment is just because I
seek to do not my own will but the will
of him who said to me so he if he's God
who's he being sent by yes exactly
okay and again can do nothing on his own
John 14 28
did you say that you're not believing
Jesus you have stepped outside of his
name you can not be a Muslim is
attending our faith to believe in and
love Jesus Christ I would say this thing
that you just told me it's not in the
scripture and they would say a marginal
note added by scribe yeah okay we know
that and I'd be thinking if you know
this is not the Bible why are you
preaching it as if it's gospel truth
okay you heard me say to you I am going
away and I am coming to you if you loved
me you would rejoice that I am going to
the Father because the father is greater
than I very clear very unambiguous yeah
John 20:17
I like this one this John 20:17 I've
okay Jesus said to her do not hold on to
me because I have not yet ascended to
the Father but go to my brothers and say
to them I am ascending to my father and
your father and to my god and your God
so so if there's any equivalence here
it's between Jesus and other humans yeah
clearly he's telling you that he's going
to your God and my God he's not God so
Jesus praised the God it says in Matthew
14 23 oh we have many many examples of
that I don't know whether it's worth
reading all of them but Matthew 14 23
and after you dismissed the crowds he
went up the mountain by himself to pray
when the evening came he was there alone
and so forth and so on and the issue is
you pray to someone obviously you are
subordinate to them yeah you know you
you were of a lesser status certainly a
lesser rank how about if someone says
you know what and I've heard this before
that he was teaching them how to pray to
God to himself
when I was like one could make the
argument yeah he certainly did a lot of
repetitive teaching them yeah
how about how would you explain and I've
heard this mentioned before also that
Thomas had came and worship Him said my
Lord and my god
yeah very ambiguous mmm-hmm
don't surprise me with something
anything you you're pregnant
my lord of my god wait a minute
what what what does this mean you know
am I simply doing an exclamation Thomas
sees Jesus he thinks Jesus is dead Jesus
is right there yeah he says my lord my
god what are we interpret from this yeah
okay so we have overwhelming amount of
evidence that is clear unambiguous
unequivocal showing that you don't
really even need a master's degree in
theology to see that hey you know Jesus
is making a distinction between him and
God oh absolutely
then you have other verses that are you
know verses that are equivocal that
they're open to many to interpretations
and why do you think people that they
tend to want to take these to really try
to justify this belief if you got all
these other verses that are clear well
yeah I know I don't want to imply that
people are deliberately yeah you know
cherry-picking biblical verses etc I
think the thing is you have to
appreciate people who have probably
raised in Sunday school etc yeah you
know they've been taught from the word
go a certain view etc and and when they
read biblical verses that are ambiguous
they quite naturally and automatically
project onto them the sort of story that
they were taught back in Sunday school
when they were children so it's kind of
just wanting to stick to what maybe your
grandparents forefathers you know you're
defending something that you know you
just want to really fit you want to make
sense and I mean
there's a person just go to any bounds
to do that you think no no I and again I
think you're implying more
intentionality than yeah often is I mean
people have been trained to understand
things in a certain way yeah by virtue
of their you know going to Sunday school
every Sunday as a kid etc yeah I'm going
to Vacation Bible School etc and so when
they read things they just naturally
read them with that interpretation in
mind it's not that they're willfully
distorting or willfully trying to prove
a point I think as much as it is they've
been trained to look at it this way and
they have never stopped and checked
themselves and say no wait a minute what
are all the different possible ways that
this verse can be understood yeah you
know that they're sort of going on
automatic pilot yes based upon how they
were taught how the story was presented
to them when they were children
let's explain to the people now really
who Jesus was and who God is the true
concept of God that I think if any
rational person sincere person when he
hears this it's just going to fit with
what God already embedded in all of us
well leus Muslims believe that God is
one and that's a very emphatic one that
he is incomparable nothing could compare
with him that he is greater than
anything you can name yes which is what
was meant when a Muslim says Allah Akbar
yeah God is greater
it's greater than this is greater than
that you can't compare God to anything
and as far as conceptualizing God you
know we humans our minds are too too
minuscule to finite we can't ever get a
totally comprehensive mental
understanding of God he's beyond our
human intellect that is the greatness
and the majesty and the awesomeness of
God but there are some things we can't
say God is unity God is one God is love
this is one of the names of God we find
in the Quran al what dude the loving God
is the loving God is the compassionate
Auto Rahman yes another one of the names
for God mentioned in the Quran God is
the merciful ar-rahim another one of the
names of God mentioned in the Quran so
we as Muslims see God as one as
incomparable as being a loving
compassionate and merciful God also a
just God yes but a God that is loving
compassionate and merciful and the true
nature of Jesus what does a Muslim
believe about this messenger that Jesus
was fully human but that obviously as a
prophet and Messenger of God he stood in
a special relationship with God one that
those of us who are not prophets and
messengers are not fortunate enough to
have yeah but someone who has been given
a direct revelation from God certainly
is standing in a closer proximity to God
than then the rest of us mere mortals
are now you had talked about identity in
your story on how you came to Islam
how can someone overcome because I'm
sure when they hear this it just makes
good old common sense again you
graduated from Harvard with a master's
in divinity but I don't think a person
needs that master's in divinity to just
use the tools that God has given him
when you just define who God is and his
pure oneness his absoluteness in that
oneness and His mercy and it's not
something that is too complicated you
don't have to do all this mental
gymnastics to try to make this fit but
now it's the identity now a person is
nervous this is like what I know this is
what I do this is what you know they
feel like this is me and now they get
stuck with this how did they overcome
this well first of all let me reinforce
what you were saying
the Quran says that the signs of God are
all around us you know all we have to do
is stop take a look around us begin to
calm
complained the world that God has
created and will find God
you know the Quran talks about Abraham
peace be upon him reasoning to
monotheism by naturalistic observation
by studying the disguise yeah and he was
able to reason apparently as a youth of
about page 14 reasoning to absolute
monotheism
so yes the signs are all around us and
and those signs are available to
everyone now what happens when a person
gets to that point of saying God is one
one and only one but why you know I've
been raised as a Christian yeah you know
what are my parents going to say what
are my answers uncle's gonna say what
about my friends and and my goodness do
I have to start wearing this you know
slip like dress and wearing something on
my head you're not wearing no I'm not
wearing do I have to change my name
yeah no the answer is no to all of those
things and and I would say to our
Christian friends who are listening who
may be thinking about Islam you know
don't don't let an overzealous Muslim
tell you you have to change your name
you don't or tell you you have to dress
in Middle Eastern clothing you don't or
or try to convince you to be more of an
Arab than an Arab or more of a Pakistani
than a Pakistani are more of an
Indonesian than an Indonesian
you don't have to do any of that you
know if you're born here you were raised
here
you're an American that's your identity
nationally and culturally keep it
actually you probably don't have much
choice in that matter but keep it
there's nothing antithetical about being
an American and national cultural
identity and being a Muslim and
religious identity you know Muslims have
been in this country for centuries and
I've contributed significantly to this
country for
trees so there's no conflict between
being an American being a Muslim rest
assured on that point we'd like to thank
you once again for being with us my
pleasure thank you just luck while
having God Almighty the creator that
happens in earth Allah rewards you in
abundance and we'd like to thank you for
being sincere
wanting to know the truth and I hope
that you continue on your mission
searching for the truth for those of you
who are ready know what the truth is try
to every day live it and be the best
example that you can be so other people
can see you living the truth and they
can see it in your character and your
behavior and then they're going to want
to ask questions what are these people
on they're honest they have great
integrity they don't lie they don't back
bite they don't gossip they stay away
from gambling from fornicating from all
the different evil vices around the
world and then they'll come to know that
you're living the way of life that all
the messengers of God lived
you're being humbly and sincerely
submissive to the one who created you
not to a man to a woman but the one who
created man and woman not to the Sun to
the moon but the one who created the Sun
in the moon you're praying like Jesus
prayed you praying like Abraham prayed
you're a Muslim one who has consciously
surrendered and submitted to the one God
in Arabic that's a Muslim it's very
simple it's a unique way of life is for
everybody and we hope that you got to
benefit and you keep coming back until
next time assalamu alaikum peace be unto
you